nous allons censé votre télé matin sur
France 2 avec l'ami Jean-Baptiste
marteau ah on n'était pas l'antenne on
est de retour
comment ça va Jean-Baptiste
ce matin ça parle dans tous les sens les
Bleus de Sainte-Geneviève les Ginette
face au rouge de Auch
deux lycées d'une ville habituellement
tranquille Versailles
[Applaudissements]
ça ne saute pas aux yeux mais ils sont
les futurs élites de la France
[Applaudissements]
soeur faut replacer cette séquence qui
sort de 15 jours de débat de débat il
n'y en a pas eu et vous avez des députés
qui sortent qui sont contents d'avoir
obstrués qui chantent on est là voilà le
niveau de ces gens là
c'est la bêtise et la vulgarité même
jusqu'où timbre de la vente quelle
vulgarité non mais vraiment c'est
vulgaire
on est sur la défense des amendements
maintenant allez-y madame kéké vous avez
la parole
excusez-moi
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
de Président je vous prie de m'excuser
allez-y tous les noirs ne se ressemblent
pas et oui c'est un slam spécial
catholique aujourd'hui Joseph et Marie
sont avec nous et nous avons pas l'un
des apôtres avec nous
bienvenue ça va Joseph c'est drôle
d'avoir Joseph et Marie à côté on l'a
pas fait exprès indécence honte minable
voilà ce qu'inspire cette vidéo de Dylan
Thierry influenceur français partie en
Turquie après le séisme les réseaux
sociaux redis c'est vraiment un fléau
c'est le fléau pour moi de ce siècle
c'est une catastrophe et je pense que
les mecs qui sont à la tête des réseaux
sociaux ce sont insta que ce soit
Twitter ou que ce soit imparfait
Facebook après c'est autre chose
Facebook c'est très bien je trouve que
Facebook il y a un bon régulateur tout
ça Facebook
tout ça les mecs je peux vous dire ils
vont avoir des comptes à rendre bientôt
il faut dire que l'homme fait l'objet de
plusieurs plaintes pour il y a des
cagnottes en ligne prétendument
humanitaires et la visite de sa chambre
d'hôtel à Istanbul ne va pas restaurer
son image c'est un hôtel à Istanbul qui
est magnifique salle de bain en marbre
noir c'est un miracle tous les 2009
ah comment ça se passe au niveau de la
caméra il y a pas de blessé je vois
qu'il y a une barque qui est tombé tout
va bien merci beaucoup c'est Casper le
fantôme du film
c'est vrai tu as fini de la beauté bon
j'ai hâte de voir le résultat ce qui
s'est donné là viens on va voir si ça
ferme
ça y est
[Musique]
nos cours Facebook et instagram bientôt
au payant les utilisateurs australiens
néo-zélandais font inauguré cette
semaine une nouvelle option s'ils
veulent d'authentifier leur compte avec
un badge bleu ils devront débourser au
moins 12 dollars par mois ce sera
probablement autant en euros quand ce
sera au tour de la France après Twitter
l'entreprise meta choisit également de
faire payer ses utilisateurs pour faire
face à ces difficultés financières en
tout cas l'objectif pour métal à maison
mère de facebook d'Instagram et de
WhatsApp et d'arrondir les fins de mois
de l'entreprise qui traversent une
période difficile le cours de bourse de
la société a été divisé par 3 en
l'espace d'un an 11000 employés ont été
licenciés au cours du mois de novembre
et le groupe est donc à la recherche de
revenus complémentaires un changement de
stratégie et de philosophie pour
Facebook dont le slogan a longtemps été
c'est gratuit et ça le restera toujours
vous avez demandé de raboter la porte
bon on va maintenant elle ferme bien
mais il y a un autre petit mais comment
ça bah avec la scie sauteuse c'est
pareil
non mais franchement sérieux j'ai jamais
vu ça de ma vie j'en ai la chair de
poule
non mais attends
une oeuvre de Jeff Koons brisée en mille
morceaux lors d'un vernissage à Miami
une collectionneuse a fait tomber par
accident un petit balloon dog c'est
chien ballon en verre qui ont fait la
renommée du sculpteur américain valeur
de l'oeuvre près de 40000 euros sur
place certains semblent choqués sur les
réseaux sociaux beaucoup moins l'artiste
figure de l'art contemporain est décrié
et cela se ressent dans les commentaires
car certains relativise pas grave
c'était moche ce qui fait réagir ce
matin au 32 16 Arnaud et bien c'est
cette décision de Gérald de Darmanin qui
propose de retirer automatiquement le
permis à toute personne qui se serait
fait contrôler en voiture sous l'emprise
de supiant d'alcool oui c'est évidemment
une réponse à la faire Palmade Gérald
Darmanin applique une méthode bien
connue un fait divers une loi c'est une
sorte de mini Sarkozy Gérald Darmanin
mais en plus grand on peut très bien
avoir passé une soirée à la maison un
mercredi soir et avoir fumer
il ne serait-ce que
conduire 5 jours après et vous nous
dites ouais vous êtes positif c'est la
rétention de permis ça c'est pas cool je
m'en souviens très très bien ce monsieur
en plus de ça je peux vous mimer son nom
si vous le souhaitez alors allez-y
ah oui c'est vrai il avait un nom de
voiture de sport en fait le deuxième
fois
c'est une Porsche non
en fait
[Rires]
je rappelle pour ceux qui viennent de
tomber sur notre hôtel
et
constipédia
je peux pas malheureusement
un peu
tout ça déjà été dit sur la tragédie
Palmade en plus il y a cette affaire de
pédopornographie maintenant
plus spé depuis si c'est avéré on sait
comment ça va se finir pour Palmade
Bolloré va lui confier une émission sur
C8 news en tout cas les propos
ça va vous la digérer correctement